[Music]
the metropolitan police of the time
eliminated the mandatory requirement of
the cob vaccine and hello how are you
andré gonzález cheering you on with his brief
information from iu news now in spanish
until now all new employees
of the department had to be
fully vaccinated against  the hobbit the
department indicated that this
change occurs because the positive cases
for covite began to drop
the police union is in favor of
this change
and a new video shows the dodge
challenger at the time before the
fatal accident that occurred in north  las
vegas surveillance cameras
show this vehicle going over 100
miles per hour about to eat strike
seconds later this same car runs through
a red light causing a
multi-car accident where nine
people lost their lives and
for those in  job seeker
I tell you that the circus circus of las
vegas' will organize a job fair to
hire more  of 100 people in
different departments these are in
hotels games of chance
family games near the pool among
others the fair takes place from 3 to 7 in the
afternoon dress to impress since you
will be able to get an interview in the
same place
and now we are going to see  the weather forecast
the temperatures will be
reaching almost 50 degrees for today
a cold day is expected with a lot of wind
the temperatures will drop approximately
10 degrees also the wind will
feel colder with a speed of 40
miles per hour this will extend
until  Thursday beautiful day andrés
gonzález greets you with his cold information from
inusa or in Spanish
[Música]